the false allure of victimology that's
the focus of tonight's angle after
seeing your really strong reaction to
last night's show about how universities
are breeding grounds for victimhood and
manufactured anger we thought it was
important to expand on this theme
tonight and given today's developments
on a number of stories this conversation
we're gonna have on the Ingraham angle
tonight is more important than ever the
superintendent of the Chicago Police was
visibly understandably outraged by what
his department and the community has
endured because of Jessie small it's
fabricated hate crime we discovered the
actual motive quite frankly it pissed
everybody else you know because we have
to invest valuable resources a lot of
what I want you all to really understand
is when you all put things out there
into the universe that's not actually
fast then it causes us to have to chase
all that stuff down those resources in
time spin that we'll never get back oh
that's all well and good I guess but
poor Jessie making a boatload of money
per year it looks like he was driven to
this by his warped view of celebrity
income inequality this announcement
today recognizes that Empire actor Jesse
Smollett took advantage of the pain and
anger of racism to promote his career
and why this stunt was orchestrated by
some lette because he was dissatisfied
with his salary now what drove Smollett
a supporting actor on the Fox show
Empire to think that this stunt
this victim narrative that he'd been
assaulted by Magha hat-wearing thugs
would get him a pay raise Wow probably
because he had seen others profit from
the same routine and never get penalized
there has been a long line of celebrity
victims in recent years people known
only for their self-proclaimed
to hood there was colin kaepernick who
after staging his kneeling protests and
disrupting the entire sport of football
claimed he was being victimized by NFL
owners who were keeping him from playing
just because of his activism believed in
something even if it means sacrificing
everything so don't ask if your dreams
are crazy ask if they're crazy enough
well of course you got a
multimillion-dollar Nike contract and a
hefty NFL settlement out of the whole
deal
so you see victimhood pays and then of
course there was Christine blase Ford
like smollett Ford turned on the drama
for the cameras and even when her
charges didn't hold water no
substantiation she was still invited by
Sports Illustrated to be an awards
presenter before the glitterati
I am honored to speak with you from afar
about a woman I admire so much Rachel
Dunn Hollander I am in all of you and I
will always be inspired by you now it's
obvious for anyone capable of objective
thought if you're a liberal and you have
an outrageous claim that implicates
conservatives or President Trump
what do they all stand for well you'll
probably get national attention you'll
get high-profile interviews you'll be on
magazine covers and of course you'll get
a lot of money
blase Ford made out like Batman raking
in over 800,000 dollars via a GoFundMe
account it was all for her security and
for a politically active Trump hating
minor celebrity like Jessie Smollett the
lesson was learned victimhood pays and
often handsomely
crying racism would be his ticket to
fame and fortune heck it beats playing
second fiddle to taraji Henson on a show
whose ratings were already on the
downslope
you think you're talking to so he
decided to write his own new role where
the character would be someone important
a moral crusader on a mission to warn
the whole country about the dangers of
trump now the absurd details of his
phony attack confirmed all of the worst
most toxic of left-wing caricatures of
Trump followers that there this new
breed of Klansmen waiting around the
corner of every major city to assault
and Lynch black and gay liberals so
suddenly it was like 1955 and Birmingham
all over again kind of like a really bad
Spike Lee film or something and then
when the fantasy came crashing down and
police began to discover the lies a real
truth well the pair of brothers buying
supplies those Nigerian brothers and the
coordinated phone calls the evidence was
overwhelming that Smollett had committed
a poisonous fraud in America so
naturally some all its media
co-operators blamed conservatives we're
going to see conservative media probably
play this up a bit
Sean Hannity is gonna eat just a small
let's lunch every single second Tucker
Carlson is going to eat justly small
that's lunch every single second icing
it up the President of the United States
is gonna eat his lunch unreal so it's
like heads they win tails we lose Trump
supporters are guilty no matter what no
matter how agree just the underlying
fraud doesn't matter and it should not
surprise any of us that today's
Democrats cling to this victimhood
narrative with a political death grip
after all what do they have to do
without it you know with their lame
track record how can they possibly
convince African Americans that they're
gonna do better be better off and
they're gonna have their wages lift it
up better or they're gonna have the
their neighborhoods safer cartels are
gonna be kept out of their neighborhoods
gang members I'm s 13 I'm going to be
out of their communities the the
Democrats are somehow be better Trump
that creating jobs the answer is they
can't argue
any of that because they have no
substantive arguments but they can and
they do sell victimhood and for that
they have a lot of buyers this is how
kanye west put it about a year ago and a
pair of tweets he said there was a time
when slavery was the trend and
apparently that time is still upon us
but now it's a mentality then he wrote
self victimization is a disease well you
bet it is because when any of us claim
to cling to victimhood we give away our
power our power to solve problems and to
better ourselves the old-fashioned way
it's through something called hard work
and it's important to understand the
left strategy here they'll use
fabricated tales of victimization to
divert attention from other inconvenient
truths now remember it was Smollett who
crashed in and took the focus off of
Virginia Governor Ralph blackface
Northam of course and his lieutenant
governor Justin Fairfax who is accused
by at least two women of sexual abuse
boy that Virginia's story faded fast
didn't it and now that small it's
anti-trump drama has blown up the media
has jumped on the story of that
whack-job Coast Guard lieutenant who
wanted to murder Democrat politicians
this is now the second time that we know
about from the pipe bombs to yesterday
it's exactly what Donald Trump is
encouraging words are cheap to him but
they have cost elsewhere you look at
this man if he's hearing that the media
is the enemy of the people
and we all know the recent history of
violence propelled in some part by the
president's rhetoric again this is so
predictable it's almost boring but
notice that when conservatives are truly
victimized physically attacked when
conservatives are actually targeted and
shot for their political beliefs like
Congressman Steve Scalise the media they
have no time for that it's as if it
never happened
in fact Nancy Pelosi admonished
Republicans against laying blame on
Democrats for that attack
I don't even want to go into the
President of the United States but in
terms of some of the language that he
has used when you have all the assaults
that are made on Hillary Clinton huh for
them to be so sanctimonious is something
but it didn't used to be this way
somewhere in the 90s
Republicans decide on a politics of
personal destruction as they went after
the Clintons and that is the provenance
of it and that's what has continued well
despite the shooters devotion for Bernie
Sanders conservatives didn't rush in to
connect the Vermont senator to the
shooting nor did they try to link small
it's criminal actions to his political
heroes Barack Obama and Maxine Waters
because to link them would be unfair and
it would be just plain stupid but many a
antitrump partisans in the media felt
obligated to connect Donald Trump and
his supporters to a story that was
ludicrous from the get-go what he said
happened to him sort of fit in with an
arat not a narrative but a reality for a
lot of people in this country since
President Trump was inaugurated and you
think about what just happened to Jesse
Smollett in Chicago unfortunately we
have racism germinating from the white
house if you were in a position of power
and you hate people and you want to
cause suffering to them what do you
think is going to happen and people are
going to be beaten on the street well
the modern democratic movement has
abandoned the optimism and the idealism
of John F Kennedy people like Patrick J
morena Han and now it's activist court
pedals non-stop anger in resentment so
in a decade just a short decade they've
gone from a hope and change to hate and
rage and when 2020 comes around I
somehow doubt the message of your a
victim will be let's be victorious and
that's the angle